hidden deep within Northern California's
redwood forest stands a grove of some
ancient trees they were discovered by
researchers back in 1998 who decided to
keep the location a secret but as John
Blackstone reports someone posted the
coordinates on social media and now
tourists are threatening the thousand
year old trees what a place to work yeah
it's not bad office setting entering the
redwood forest is like stepping back in
time
among all the towering trees the exact
location of the tallest named the grove
of titans has long been kept secret to
help preserve them the early management
philosophy was we're not gonna tell
people we're still not telling people
but for a long time that worked
Brett silver has agreed to lead me to
the Titans he's acting superintendent
for Redwood National and state parks
home to some of the largest trees in the
world so this is not an official state
park trail no this is one of the trail
that visitors of created by searching
for the some of the trees and grove the
Titans a few years ago someone posted
the GPS coordinates of the Titans on
social media images like this lured
thousands of tourists to the area in
search of the secret Grove they criss
crossed the park creating unofficial
trails known as social trails and
calling it the grove of the Titans a
secret grove that just enhanced the hunt
yeah
piqued people's interest people got it
kind I think intrigued into like the big
tree huh almost like trophy hunters and
like trophy hunters people posed with
the Titans sharing them online as proof
of their conquest you can see the kind
of steps leading higher and higher so
they can get that perfect picture but
forest ecologist later bleonard studies
the damage done by foot traffic along
with destroying native plants the soil
compaction caused by standing next to a
redwood harms the roots the tree is so
tall so enormous hard to believe that
you know a few people hanging around
down here is gonna do it harm most of
the roots of a redwood tree are in the
first three feet or so everything they
need are up right near the surface and
it kills the small roots where nutrients
are taken up into the tree to help
the tree grow so you can see the where
we're selling them putting their hand or
a foot there's another piece where they
even stepping on broken bark also leaves
the redwoods vulnerable to insects and
disease and while some live 2,000 years
more than 95% of all California's
redwoods have been lost cutting their
way into trees that may be as old as our
civilization the logging industry
followed the gold rush into California
decimating the redwoods now the redwood
parks Conservancy is raising money to
protect the Titans you walk into an
old-growth Grove it really is just a
humbling experience it puts everything
in perspective it puts life in
perspective 1.4 million dollars is
needed to build raised walkways that
would allow for selfies without
endangering the health of the trees the
Park Service says it's likely a
three-year project in the meantime I
know it's kind of a reach people go
you're gonna ask people to stay on trail
yes because that's our only defense
right now by staying on the trails
visitors can still see the forest and
save the trees for CBS this morning John
Blackstone Crescent City California I
was wondering what was wrong with it but
now I get it all the people trampling
over it
destroying the roots but the idea raised
of raised walkway is such a shame those
trees they're so majestic Oh beautifully
shot piece - I want to go yeah me too